so there's lots of reasons you could
have rage attacks depression anxiety
feeling out of control of your life or
invisible to the people you love so many
fun reasons for me I found that when I
suddenly find myself filled with anger
with no discernible reason it's often
because I've had poor boundaries whether
by being polite and agreeing to
something I don't want to do hey do you
mind helping me get rid of this body
yeah yeah of course I can or allowing
someone to negate my emotions wow that
makes me really upset no it doesn't well
yeah yes it does
no it doesn't okay
boundaries are these weird and visible
and symbolic fences that are meant to
allow us to protect an assert or
authentic selves and they're in every
facet of our lives I mean we have
emotional boundaries physical boundaries
spiritual and intellectual boundaries
and of course sexual boundaries some
being stronger than others so I'm
available Monday Wednesday and Friday
evenings with the occasional Saturday
morning but absolutely no two
consecutive nights in a row though I am
okay with the morning following evening
permitted that you weren't drinking the
night before and if you were Mints are a
hundred percent necessary Wow okay let
me just let me just take some notes here
also missionary preferred other
positions available but it really
depends on how many breeded i am and if
you're like me and you tend to have
really bad boundaries you'll often find
that you're resentful of yourself and
others because you're often in
situations you don't want to be in and
the thing is we only have ourselves to
blame I mean bad boundaries are learned
but good boundaries can be relearned and
it starts with taking responsibility for
your actions and emotions so sexy I know
we fear being rude or people not liking
us or being viewed in a certain way so
in the moment it's easier to violate our
own boundaries and say yes to things we
secretly don't want to do Anna do you
want a fake crime tonight uh yeah sure
okay let's go great um
crime never sleeps and them away okay
yeah right now okay let's go reading a
really good poetry book about death
really no pants on okay but the thing is
by not vocalizing our boundaries we're
disrespecting ourselves and boundaries
you know are flexible and dynamic and
constantly changing depending on the
context so it's something that you just
have to listen to your gut about I mean
you'll know when something isn't sitting
right with you don't bulldoze over your
intuition because you're afraid of a
little confrontation it is possible to
assert yourself without being a dick hey
I'm sorry I would I would love to help
you get rid of his body but it seems
like it's just gonna be a really like
physically taxing thing and I've just
got too much work on my plate right now
so if you find yourself randomly upset
check in are you needlessly over
exerting yourself are you saying yes
when you really mean no are you letting
someone just take over what you want and
if the answer is yes get excited to have
a lot of uncomfortable conversations
because the rewards are worth it hey I'm
so sorry to interrupt but I don't use my
phone past 10 p.m. anymore so I'm really
sorry but I'm great okay okay good luck
with everything that you're doing I am
rooting for you go box honestly thank
you to Squarespace for sponsoring
today's video Squarespace has
award-winning templates and all-in-one
platforms there's no installs patches or
upgrades ever if you don't have a domain
Squarespace offers a simple and unique
set up experience plus if you ever run
into an issue they have 24-hour customer
service go to Squarespace comm / ana to
start your free trial today and use the
offer code ana for 10% off a check